Speaker 1: Let's get back to you the audience
via discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord
so that we can learn from people. Let's
try Steve from the Bay Area again. Steve,
you bailed on me when I went to you at the
top of the show. But you are back. I'm sure.
Now you have a great question for me.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I'm really sorry
about that. It was my first time calling
in. I got a little nervous. Didn't have
a question, really. But now I.
Speaker 1: Do. I hear it and it
almost sounds. Do you have it written down? I
thought I just heard a piece of paper shuffle.
Speaker 3: Oh, just moving a bag of fruit. Oh,
okay. Anyways, so I'm probably one of those
random, rare people that is a progressive and
a Christian as well. Okay. And I know a lot of
people, including myself, have a bad taste
in their mouth over the evangelical right.
And there are. I just wanted to let you
know that there are a minority of us. Sadly,
we are a minority that is fighting for, you
know, the actual love and of our neighbor as
as Jesus talked about. So I'm just wondering,
have you met many Christians that, like,
are on that side of the progressive like Bernie
vibe and and what's your experience with them?
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, I, I haven't met
hundreds, but I've certainly met and know in
my personal life, 1 to 2 dozen people who are
progressive Christians. We've interviewed some
progressive Christians. Yeah. Also progressive.
I mean, I guess progressive Catholics is more
common. Catholics, I think, tend to be more left
than certainly evangelicals. I guess I would say
no. But I know, I know. Born again Christians
who are are left. I don't know that they're
Bernie necessarily, but they're certainly on the
left. And soon we're actually our friend. Benjamin
Dixon is doing some great work from within
Christianity to fight Christian nationalism.
He's a progressive Christian. And yeah, it's
not it's not the rarest thing in the world.
Speaker 3: Yeah, for sure. I really follow
an organization called Red Letter Christians,
and they really try to focus on kind of the
words that Jesus said in the Bible and whether
you believe it or not. And that's fine. I know
you're not particularly religious, but, you know,
there are those of us out there who read the
Bible for ourselves and are like, maybe we should
actually do those nice things and treat people
with respect and not push our beliefs on others.
Speaker 1: Now, where are
Christians like you on abortion?
Speaker 3: I am pro-choice. Interesting.
Speaker 1: And what is the scriptural
justification in your mind?
Speaker 3: I don't think there's
I don't think the Bible even discusses abortion.
Speaker 1: Just the Bible is
a non-issue to view on abortion.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I think that overall there's more
good done to to support abortion rather than you
know stick people that would seek one usually for
financial reasons because they kind of, you know,
can support one. Yeah, that's about half the time.
And why would we assume those people
should bring up children and, you know,
saddle them with that kind of burden and stuff?
So and most of them happen in the first trimester
anyways when I don't really think that's a life.
Speaker 1: I mean it makes a lot of sense
to me. And then how about on gay marriage?
Speaker 3: My brother is gay, so and he's married.
And I mean, I guess if I if if I was pressured,
I'm probably like, you know, anti gay marriage
personally, but like, I wouldn't vote against
it, I guess. And I love my brother and I support
him. And I know that probably sounds bad to.
Speaker 1: Like you wouldn't get a gay marriage,
but you're okay with other people doing it.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, I like. I like girls,
but. Right. No, but I understand. I also
have a lot of empathy for people who do have
attraction to the same sex. Because I know if I
was in that situation, it would be really tough.
And I don't know if I if I would square that with
my faith. So I'd have to personally figure it out.
Speaker 1: You I'm guessing from what you're
saying, you don't think people choose to be gay?
Speaker 3: No, definitely not. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Well,
very interesting. I appreciate your insights.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: There we go. Progressive
Christians. Very, very interesting.